Hallo ihr Lieben! Heute gibt's eine klassische Erdbeertorte.
Das ist eine Torte, die immer geht. Und ich habe mir diesmal auch überlegt
ich mache sie so einfach wie möglich damit  jeder sie nachmachen kann!
Wir machen jetzt erstmal den Boden und das ist nicht mein klassischer Biskuitboden
wie ihr jetzt vielleicht erwartet habt. Denn der Biskuitboden, der  ist zwar meiner Meinung nach
auch einfach zu machen wenn man jeden Schritt beachtet aber es ist halt so, dass man
das Eiweiß trennt und separat aufschlägt und und und, Hamza kennt sogar das Prozedere.
(H: *stolz* Jaa!)
Und heute hab ich mir überlegt: wir machen das so, dass wir einen Wunderkuchen backen.
Der geht folgendermaßen: ich habe jetzt hier meine Küchenmaschine
und geb da zuallererst mal Eier rein. Die müsst ihr nicht trennen, einmal komplett rein.
Dann habe ich hier natürlich Zucker, den gebe ich auch direkt mit rein.
Vanilleextrakt für den Geschmack und dann schlagen wir das Ganze 8min lang auf maximaler Geschwindigkeit
richtig schön hell-cremig.
Jetzt ist die Eier-Zucker Masse hell-cremig und als nächstes rühren wir ganz kurz unsere flüssigen Zutaten
mit unter. Das wäre einmal Milch und Rapsöl. Statt Rapsöl könntet ihr auch Sonnenblumenöl verwenden.
Aber was ihr auf keinen Fall benutzen dürft ist Olivenöl z.B. weil das schmeckt zu intensiv,
das ist fürs Backen in dem Fall also nicht geeignet. So, einmal rein und ihr seht auch anhand der
Verpackungen und Flaschen: ich habe natürlich wieder mal bei Kaufland eingekauft.
Und dieses Video ist auch in Zusammenarbeit mit meinem Lieblingssupermarkt Kaufland entstanden.
So und jetzt rühre ich das ganz kurz ein, grad nur so ein paar Sekunden
und danach verrühre ich Mehl und Backpulver miteinander.
Die trockenen Zutaten dann hinein sieben und für 10sek unterrühren
und dann füllen wir den Teig in unsere Springform - ich habe eine 24cm Springform -
den Boden mit Backpapier auslegen und so ein bisschen glatt verstreichen.
Und jetzt backen wir unseren Boden bei 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze - im vorgeheizten Backofen,
das ist ganz wichtig - für ca 40 min und lassen ihn dann zugedeckt vollständig auskühlen.
Während der Boden auskühlt kümmere ich mich um die Erdbeercreme, die ist super lecker und sehr sehr frisch
denn später kam noch pürierte Erdbeeren mit hinzu. Aber jetzt erstmal zur Schlagsahne:
die sollte ganz kalt aus dem Kühlschrank kommen. Ich habe gerade auch Schüssel
und Schneebesenaufsatz in den Kühlschrank gegeben für 5min,
dann kann euch auch nichts mehr schiefgehen. Einmal einfüllen und dann schlage ich das erst langsam
und dann gehe ich mit der Geschwindigkeit immer höher und lass  Sahnefest einrieseln bis es komplett steif ist.
So, jetzt ist die Sahne steif. Die kommt nur ganz kurz an die Seite, die restlichen Zutaten verrühre ich jetzt
hier in meiner Schüssel. Da habe ich wieder unser Trio und zwar Mascarpone, Magerquark und Sahne.
Ihr könnt auch statt Mascarpone Doppelrahmfrischkäse nehmen oder wenn ihr sagt ihr möchtet den
komplett weglassen, dann habe ich auch einen Tipp für euch: dann ersetzt ihr die Menge halb und halb
eben durch Sahne und Magerquark. Das schreibe ich euch ganz genau nochmal in die Videobeschreibung
falls es jetzt zu verwirrend sein sollte.
So, einfach alles rein geben.
Magerquark auch noch mit dazu.
Und dann habe ich schon mal Erdbeeren püriert und die siebe ich jetzt noch dazu
damit ich diese kleinen Stückchen nicht drin hab.
Für die Süße und für den Geschmack noch Puderzucker und Vanilleextrakt dazugeben
und jetzt nehm' ich mir meinen Schneebesen und verrühre das.
Und anschließend hebe ich mit einem Teigschaber die Sahne unter.
So und kleiner Geheimtipp: ich hab jetzt hier noch ein bisschen Lebensmittelfarbe dazu geben!
(H: *flüstert* Ja, nicht so laut reden, ja?)
Ja, das ist ja ein Geheimtipp, deswegen rede ich so leise! Damit es eben auch schön aussieht.
(H: *flüstert* Ahhhh! Was für ein geiler Tipp ey!)
(H: Aber sieht echt schön aus!)
Unsere Creme ist fertig, die Böden habe ich zweimal durchgeschnitten damit ich 3 Böden erhalte
und jetzt müssten wir eigentlich alles nur noch schichten.
Dafür nehme ich mir jetzt eine Tortenplatte. Also ich platziere meine Torten immer gerne direkt
auf den Tortenplatten damit ich später den Transport nicht mehr hab. So und da gebe ich jetzt den ersten
Boden einmal drauf, spanne einen Tortenring drum herum und dann fange ich an
mit ein paar Esslöffeln der Creme. Und was ich auch noch mache - weil ich möchte echt
die geballte Ladung Erdbeeren - ich geb' da noch frische klein geschnittene Erdbeeren dazwischen.
Und wenn wir ganz oben angekommen sind, dann sage ich euch, wie wir weitermachen.
Die Tortenoberfläche jetzt noch ganz dünn mit der Creme einstreichen damit sie auch nicht austrocknet.
Und dann geben wir sie für 30min in den Kühlschrank damit alles schön sitzt, schön fest wird
und wir den Tortenring entfernen können. Dafür schnappt ihr euch jetzt den Backformlöser,
geht da einmal an dem Rand entlang und dann hebt ihr den Tortenring an,
und dann haben wir ja noch Creme übrig, ich hab das extra schon so alles zubereitet,
dass man keine neue Creme anrühren muss. Das heißt ihr habt dann noch einiges übrig
und das brauchen wir dann nochmal um alles rundherum einzustreichen.
Das ist ein magischer Moment!
(H: Ja! Whoooooo!)
Okay, das wird ein Naked Cake.
(H: Das wird einfach geil.)
Das wird ein Naked Cake!
Der sieht so schon schön aus!
(H: Der sieht wirklich schön aus, ich würd' den genauso lassen jetzt am liebsten!)
Nee, jetzt hab ich mir was vorgenommen, jetzt werd' ich den komplett einstreichen.
(H: Den streichst du jetzt nochmal aus?)
Ja, komplett!
(H: Ah, okay!)
So, jetzt teile ich noch die Torte ein in 16 Stücke und dekoriere sie dann mit der restlichen Creme
indem ich eine Rosentülle verwende.
Und natürlich kommen auf die Oberfläche noch Erdbeeren, ist ja ganz klar!
Ich finde immer Erdbeertorten sehen einfach nur hübsch aus, allein schon wegen der Farbe und wegen der Frucht.
Wenn ihr möchtet, könnt ihr dann noch ein bisschen Kokosraspeln darüber geben, die hab ich jetzt gerade
ganz spontan aus dem Schrank geholt und noch so ein bisschen darüber gestreut.
Und jetzt ist die Torte fertig! Bitte unbedingt bis zum Anschnitt kühlen,  das ist immer ganz wichtig
bei Sahnetorten. Und ansonsten lasst's euch einfach schmecken! Die ist extrem lecker, locker,
also der Boden ist sehr saftig und die Creme sehr locker und das passt einfach perfekt zusammen!
Die ganz genauen Mengenangaben schreibe ich euch wie immer unten in die Videobeschreibung
und dann sehen wir uns auch hoffentlich bei meinem nächsten Rezept! Hinterlässt ein kostenloses Abo
damit ihr das auch nicht verpasst und dann würde ich mal sagen:
Bis zum nächsten Mal! Tschüss, eure Kiki! Und der Hamza!
(H: *mit hoher Stimme* Und der Hamza!)